let's see if we can create a linear
transformation that is a rotation
transformation through some angle theta
and what it does is it takes any vector
in r2 and it maps it to a rotated
version of that rec vector or another
way of saying it is that the rotation
let me apply let me rip it's not I don't
it's not in one of those double R's the
rotation of some vector X is going to be
equal to some counter clockwise counter
clockwise clockwise theta degree
rotation rotation of X so this is what
we want to construct using our new
linear transformation tools and just to
make sure that we can actually even do
this we need to make sure there's actual
linear transformation I'll just do that
visually because I actually don't even
have a mathematical definition for this
yet this is about as good as I've given
you so let me just draw some really fast
some axes right here I have to draw them
a little bit neater than that
that's my vertical axes that's my
horizontal axes I could call this a
little bit I'll call it this one the x1
and I'll call this the X 2 axis and the
last video I call them the X and the y
but you know this is the first component
of our vectors this is our second
component in our vectors and so if I
have some vector X if I have some vector
X like that we know that a rotation of
this a counterclockwise rotation of this
will look like this I'll do the
rotations in blue it will look like this
or this angle right here is Theta so
this right here is the rotation or an
angle of theta of X that's what this
vector right here is so what do we have
to do to make sure that this is a linear
combination we have to show two things
we have to show that the transformation
so the rotation through theta of the sum
of two vectors it's equivalent to the
sum of each of their individual
rotations the rotation of the vector X
plus the rotation of the vector Y and
I'll just show that to you
this is the vector X let's say that the
vector Y looks something like let me
draw I'll draw up both of the original
vectors in yellow so let's say the
vector Y looks like that so that's why
so what's X plus y so let's put heads to
tails if we just shift Y up here if you
just shift Y up there that's also vector
Y not drawn in standard position but X
plus y would then well it would look
pretty close to this I'm not drawing it
let me draw it a little bit neater X
plus y would look like that that would
be the vector X plus y and what would
its rotation look like through an angle
of theta
what's rotation if you just rotate this
guy through an angle of theta
I'm just approximating it would look
something like this it would look
something like that
so this right here this would be the
rotation through an angle of theta of X
plus y now let's see if that's the same
thing as if we rotate X and rotate Y and
then add them together so what's Y if we
rotate it through an angle of theta if
we rotate Y through an angle of theta
it's going to look something like it's
going to look something like it's all
approximation I should be doing it with
a ruler and a protractor maybe it looks
something like this and the rotation so
this is right here that's the rotation
of Y through an angle of theta right
there that's it the same data that I've
been doing the whole time let me make it
in a color that you can actually see so
that's that vector right there the
rotation of X was right there so if we
add the rotation of X plus the rotation
of Y I'm kind of fudging it a little bit
but I think you get the idea you
actually get so this is the rotation of
X plus the rotation of Y rotation of our
vector Y you actually get the rotation
of X plus y so at least visually it's
satisfied that first condition now the
second condition that we need for this
to be a valid linear transformation is
that the rotation the rotation through
an angle of theta of a scaled up version
of a vector it should be equal to a
scaled up version of the rotated vector
the rotated vector and I'll just do
another visual example here so let's say
this my vertical axis that's my
horizontal axis and let me say that this
is my vector X now let's draw a scaled
up version of it so a scaled up version
of X maybe just like X but it gets
scaled up a little bit so it goes all
the way it goes all the way out here so
this is my C times X and I'm going to
rotate that through an angle of theta so
if we rotate that through an angle of
theta you'll get a vector that looks
something like this rotating it
counterclockwise so this vector right
here is the rotation by an angle of
theta counterclockwise of C X that's
what this is right there now what
happens if we take the rotation of X
first so if we just rotate X first we're
going to get this vector right here so
this right here is just the rotation
through an angle of theta of X and then
we scale it up well we see it's the same
thing if this scaled up to that when you
multiply it by C then this thing is
going to scale up to that when you
multiply it by C so at least visually I
show you that I've shown you that this
is satisfied so rotation definitely is a
linear transformation at least the way
I've shown you now let's actually
construct a a mathematical definition
for let's actually construct a matrix
that will perform the transformation so
I'm saying that my rotation I'm saying
that my rotation transformation from R 2
to R 2 of some vector X can be defined
as some 2 by 2 matrix and it's 2 by 2
because it's a mapping from r2 to r2
times any vector X and I'm saying I can
do this because I have at least showing
you visually that it is indeed a linear
transformation and how do I find a well
I start with I start with since this was
mapping from R to I start with the
identity matrix in r2 which is 1 0 0 1
its columns are the basis vectors for
are to write we refer this one as e1 and
this column vector as e 2 and to figure
out a we essentially just perform the
transformation on each of these columns
so let me write that
so a our vector our trick our matrix a
is going to be the first column of it is
going to be our rotation transformation
performed on the vector 1 0 and our
second column is going to be the
rotation transformation there's a little
data here that I'm forgetting to write
times the second column vector times or
the transformation of that one 0 1 this
is what our a is going to look like so
how do we figure out what these are we
you know I'm trying to get to some
numbers and this doesn't get me there so
let's try to do that so let me draw some
more axes here let me pick a different
color I'll do it in gray so that is my
vertical axes that is my horizontal axes
and I could call this the X 1 axis and
this is the X 2 axis now this basis
vector e 1 what does it look like well
it's 1 in the horizontal X 1 is 1 and X
2 is 0 so if this is 1 out here II won
will look like that let me do it in a
more vibrant color
II won II won will look like that right
there now if I'm wrote it let me write
what eetu looks like e 2 would look like
I'll do it in yellow e 2 would look like
this right here e 2 that's that vector 0
1 this is 1 in our X 2 Direction now if
I rotate
II won by an angle theta what will it
look like so if I rotate u 1 and angle
theta I'll do it in this color right
here it will still have a length of 1
but it'll be rotated like that and that
angle right there is Theta so this right
here is the rotation of V 1 by theta
these are all vectors of course that's
what that is
now what what are the coordinates for
this or how do we
specify this this new vector how do we
specify this new vector well we can
break out a little bit of our
trigonometry its new x1 coordinate we
could call it or its x1 entry is going
to be this length right here it's going
to be this length right here so if we
draw if we draw a right triangle it is
the side that is adjacent to theta this
side is the hypotenuse which is length
one and what is so how do we figure out
this side if we call the side the
adjacent side the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse adjacent we write it over
here
adjacent over the hypotenuse which is
just one is equal to the cosine of theta
cosine of theta that comes from
sohcahtoa okay let me write that cut
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
adjacent over hypotenuse and the
adjacent side is going to be our new our
new X 1 coordinate right well we can
obviously ignore that one a divided by
one is equal to cosine theta which means
that a is equal to cosine theta which
means that this length of our rotated
vector is equal to cosine theta it's new
it's it's horizontal component or it's
horizontal coordinate is equal to cosine
of theta now if we take what's its
vertical component going to be what's
its vertical component what's a vertical
component is going to be this height
right here
it's going to be that height right there
which is the same thing as that height
right there
or we could say sine of theta then we
call this the opposite sine of theta is
equal to the opposite over one so this
is going to be equal to sine of theta
write this over one which is just this
is equal to sine of theta from sohcahtoa
so katoa so this vertical component is
equal to sine of theta so the new
rotated basis vector can be written as
cosine of theta for its X component or
for its horizontal component and sine of
theta for its vertical component this is
the new then you've rotated basis vector
now what about e two we could do
something very similar there e two is
going to end up looking like this when
you rotate it
by an angle of theta it's going to look
like that that angle right there is data
we can drop we can create a little a
little right triangle right there and so
if we want to know its x-coordinate if
we want to know its x-coordinate so now
we're concerned with the rotation
through an angle of theta of e 2 which
is that right there of e 2 this is e 2
right there this is going to be equal to
what its new x-coordinate or this first
entry in this vector if we wanted to
draw it in standard position or the
point that it is specifying is going to
be equal to this distance which is equal
to this distance on this triangle but
the coordinates going to be the negative
of this right if this is a distance of
two this coordinate is going to be -2 so
what's this we have an angle it's a
right triangle
this is opposite to the angle opposite
over one opposite over hypotenuse is
equal to cosine of theta so this
opposite side is equal to the cosine of
theta so the x-coordinate right here oh
sorry
I'm my trigonometry is messing up this
is the opposite side
sohcahtoa sine is equal to opposite let
me write it because I was sine of theta
is equal to opposite over hypotenuse so
the sine of theta sine of this angle is
equal to this opposite over the
hypotenuse the hypotenuse is 1 has
length 1 because these are the standard
basis vectors so this is equal to the
sine of theta now this distance is equal
to the sine of theta but it's going in
the negative direction so it's going to
be equal to the - minus sine of theta
and then what's its new Y component
going to be of this rotated version of
e2 well we just look right here we have
our angle this is adjacent to the a
angle this adjacent side over the
hypotenuse so adjacent over 1 which is
just this adjacent right here is just
going to be equal to cosine of theta so
it's new y-coordinate is going to be
cosine of theta so when we apply the
transformation to each of our basis
vectors we get a
is equal to the transformation applied
to e1 which is cosine of theta and sine
of theta and the transformation applied
to e 2 which is minus sine of theta
times the cosine of theta so now this I
mean this is a big result we've now been
able to mathematically specify our
rotation transformation using a matrix
so we can now say that the rotation
transformation and it's a transformation
from R 2 to R 2 it's a function we can
say that the rotation through an angle
theta of any vector X in our domain is
equal to the matrix cosine of theta sine
of theta minus sine of theta cosine of
theta times your vector in your domain
times X 1 and X 2 and you might be
saying oh Sal you know we did all this
work and that's kind of neat but how do
I apply this you know I still have all
these cosines of Thetas and sines of
theta is there how do I do it
well what you do is you pick an angle
you want to rotate to and just evaluate
these and you'll just have a normal
matrix with numbers in it so let's say
that we wanted to rotate through an
angle of 45 degrees some vector well
this is going to be equal to what we
just apply or we evaluate each of these
ratios at 45 degrees the cosine of 45
degrees is square root of 2 over 2 sine
of 45 degrees is square root of 2 over 2
sine of 45 is square root of 2 of 2 we
have a minus there so minus square root
of 2 over 2 and then times R then then
cosine is just another square root of 2
over 2 so when we multiply it times our
vector X so this matrix if we multiply
it times any vector X literally
literally so if we have some if we have
some coordinates right here and let's
say that I were to I don't know let's
say I were to have a bunch of vectors
that specify some square here let me see
if I can if I can do it properly
well maybe has some triangle here maybe
I
a little easier for me to to draw I'll
do a square let's say it has some square
here let's say I have some square here
in my domain so this is an r2 now when I
apply if I literally multiply this times
each of the basis vectors or actually
all of the vectors that specify this set
here I will get when I transform it I'll
get a rotated version of this by 45
degrees just to draw it I'll actually
draw a little 45 degree angle right
there and then it will map it to this
image to this image right there which is
a pretty neat result and I you can
always read it if you ever attempted to
write any computer game that involves
marbles or pin balls going around this
is a very useful thing to know of how do
you rotate things how do you onion the
future we'll talk about other types of
transformations but this is a super
useful one this is super hard to do and
you know I remember the first time I
wrote a computer program that try to do
this type of thing I just did it by hand
but when you have this tool at your
disposal all you have to do is evaluate
this matrix at the angle you want to
rotate by and then multiply it times
your position vectors and so you know
obviously you have a bunch of position
vectors here but here you just you can
just do it times the vertices and then
you can say okay and everything else is
just connect the dots between them and
then you have your rotated image and
just to be clear these this is these are
the points specified by a set of vectors
and I just want to make this clear right
this point right here is specified by
some position vector that looks like
that when you apply the rotation on 45
degrees of that vector this vector then
looks like this and the vector that
specified this corner right here
let me do in a different color let's
specify this corner right here when you
rotated by 45 degrees then becomes this
vector and the vector that specified
that corner over there that now becomes
this vector that's what's actually being
mapped or actually being transformed
anyway hopefully you found this pretty
neat I thought this was a at least for
me this is kind of the neat the first
really neat transformation you can
already start thinking about how to
extend this into multiple dimensions
especially three-dimensional z-- if you
ever try to actually do it by hand
dimension rotations becomes very
confusing but in the next video we'll
actually figure out a way to do
three-dimensional rotations around
certain axes